مشاهد متداول الازدحام مروري في مناطق
بلبنان بعد هروب مواطنين للشوارع جراء
الهزه الارضيه التي وقعت في منطقه هاتاي
التركيه الذي بلغت قوته
6.4.8 على مقياس ريختر نتابع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
عالم كل ظاهر
انتشر مقطع فيديو سجلته احدى السيدات في
القاهره لمشاجره بين سائقين مركبات توكتوك
على الطريق الدائري داخل القاهره ما تسبب
في ذعر وقلق بين سائقين الفيديو كشف
مشاجره بين ثلاثه سائقين كل منهم داخل
مركبته ويقود بسرعه جنونيه بين عده سيارات
معرض حياه الناس للخطر
عشان دول هيعملوا مصيبه دول هيعملوا مصيبه
ده على الدائري
مطارده تكاتك
مطارده بين التكاتك من بدري هيعملوا مصايف
في الطريق كله
بيزنقه على بعضه كانوا هيدوسوا دلوقتي
واحد
كانوا هيدوسوا الناس
راجل ومراته واقفين كانوا
ادي التكاتك واللي بناخده من التكاتك
على الدائري
مقطع فيديو متداول لكاميراتي مراقبات وثق
ولحظه خروج زياره تسلا عن السيطره في
الصين واعلنت الشرطه عن وفاه احد الركاب
واصابه اخر وهذا ولم يتم الاعلان حتى الان
عن سبب الحادثه
[موسيقى]
في مشهد غير مالوف اجتاح مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي لعباده كره قدم ينهى بالضرب على
حكم خلال مباراه في الكونغو الديمقراطيه
لعدم احتسابه ضربه جزاء لهن
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء